Hey, Nick, how are you?
Good, how are you?
I'm good too. How's everything going on?
Yeah, yeah, we're busy. We're doing pretty good. I think the whole team has dropped our ticket counts down quite a bit. Yeah, Ramal's been great, so happy with him.
Oh, great, great to hear that. I would be honest, I was a bit skeptical because he was coming in from a different environment, but yes, the positive side was that he had worked in Canada itself. So that was a positive side and that's why I can see he is ramping up very quickly.
Mm.
Oh yeah, he's doing great.
Shh.
Yeah, I don't have any problems with them. He's closing tickets. He's putting in his time. I mean, more than adequate. So, yeah, really, really good stuff from him. Haven't had any complaints. Everybody's.
Only good things I've heard from from stuff he's worked on, so...
Great, great to hear that and a good start. I would say the weekend is approaching, so a good start for my weekend.
Yeah, yeah, no, yeah, he's been great, yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
Prince.
Yeah, okay. Let me share my screen. Let me know once it's visible.
Yeah.
Okay, agenda stays the same, no changes in that. So Atlas performance is going well and he's meeting all the KPIs. Remel has been picking up and his ticket count is going well, I saw. His service are also going good. He has scored 15 service in the last 20 days.
Yep.
which is good because we have a target of 15 servers in 30 days.
Correct. Correct.
Yeah.
Atlas did a little bit of a mess up last week, but I've already talked to him about it. He had a scheduled call with a client that he didn't show up to. Unfortunately, didn't send them a message. He wasn't showing up, so there were a few people waiting on him.
Ohh.
him that day, so then I got a call from the client telling me that that wasn't acceptable. I spoke to him already about it, that he can't miss those. He's going to schedule a call like that. He's got a, and I suggested to him, you know, don't make it an exact time. Make it, you know, between 11 and 1130 in case.
Kour.
Yeah.
you know, you're on another ticket working on another call, you can't make that, but at least send a message, you know, saying, hey, I'm going to be late or let's reschedule. He didn't do any of that, which was the problem, right?
Yeah, I'll talk to him and explain him. No, no, I'll give him alternate ways of alternate ways on how not to miss any scheduled call, like scheduling it on his calendar or scheduling it in ConnectWise, other ways as well, so that he does not miss out.
I already talked to him. He's clear on the miss.
I'll not go harsh on him or something like that, but yes, I'll help him out.
Okay, yeah, because I've already talked to him, so he's agreed that was a miss, and he promised he wouldn't do it again. So I think we're okay.
Yeah.
It's okay. And then in service delivery, we know misses happen. And the biggest point is, if the engineers do acknowledge it and they agree to move forward, that's the biggest thing that we have. So again, you have already shared the feedback.
It happens, yeah.
For sure.
Correct.
Yeah, we're good.
for both of them, so thanks for that. Moving on next, on the matrix, I haven't kept Rimmel's matrix because it was just in the starting, but from next month itself, I'll add his matrix as well. Overall utilization is going good for Atlas.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's going great. And tickets, I spoke to him like, why your ticket closures are going low? He said like he's working on L1 and L2 both type of tickets. He's working on senior, so he's happy. Plus he had some leaves as well. So overall average closures per day are somewhere around 8.4.
Yeah, that's good. No, I don't have any complaints. We have been giving him some of the more difficult tickets because I see that he's able to handle those now. So I'm okay. Not really tough ones, but ones that are more tailored to a L2 type tech. So yeah, yeah, I'm good with this. No problem.
Yes.
Okay.
So, Nick, I know it's pretty early to ask. I suppose he joined in October or something. I really do not remember the date, but it was somewhere around October. Do you think in once he completes one year, he would have an eligibility to move?
Yep.
to an L2 layer with the knowledge that here.
So...
So, I mean, the problem is I can't move him unless I've got a position open for an L2, level 2. Right now I've got two others that have been here almost two years that are still L1s.
Rick.
that need to move up before him in my team at least. So even if he's at that level, I can't really move him into that L2 position on my team because I'm restricted to how many L2s versus L1s I need to have here. But yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
Correct, that's totally correct.
If there's room for it, definitely I would move him up. But like I said, I got two other L1s right now that are waiting to go to an L2 position.
Okay.
So, Nick, I just want to go into more into this because I wanted to understand, like, when my manager Vishal had a connect with Lakhwinder, he said, like, even if there is no position open in IST, they can move for a position or they can apply for a position outside IST.
Sure, absolutely. So if there's an L2 position at another team, yeah, he can definitely apply for that. That would be.
Yeah, OK.
Okay, and coming on to this question again, like you have some of the techs who are in your team and if there's any position open for L2, would you allow them or you said like there are people already in your team who are waiting for L2?
So I already moved to, I recently moved three people from an L1 to an L2 position. That when my L2s left and they went to either the tier 3 team or to projects or something, they went to a higher position. I had to.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fill those L2s, so I'm promoting within, so I moved them over to the L2 position, those guys, and then we got Ramal to cover one of those losses, and then I took a T.
Uh, L1 from another team that that uh I grabbed, so, so I feel I'm feeling I'm back feeling as I as I promote, so uh yeah.
Okay.
Okay, right.
Okay, okay, great. Just wanted to touch base on this because I wanted to be very clear on this so that if he's aspiring very much on moving next level. Yeah, so I see that enthusiasm.
Yeah, yeah, for sure. I have had.
Yep.
So if I don't have the room at that time, then yeah, he can definitely apply for another team like my other guys did and moved off the team to other positions because I didn't have room here for them.
Ohh, great.
Oh, no worries, that's really great of you. Thanks for explaining it.
Yep, yeah, no problem.
CSAT, CSAT is 100% over 27 service, so that's good. Response rate is also good. Uh, attendance or...
Yep.
Ramal was also 100% on the C stats, I checked that.
Yeah, 15 surveys all all CSATs, yeah.
Yep, yep, all good.
Atlas going good, no leaves, but there was one leave, unplanned leave on 28th May. He was not well.
Yeah, he was sick. That's right. That's right.
Yeah, so that's it.
And he's requested tomorrow.
Yeah.
I don't know if you know about that, but he he's uh...
Okay.
We guess he informed that I missed to mention here.
Sorry?
Yeah, he informed me, but I missed to mention here.
Okay, okay, yeah.
Apart from this, do you have anything to share with us? Any issue, any concerns or anything that...
No.
Just the one incident where he missed the call. Other than that, I, he's been great. Both of them have been good.
Yeah.
Oh, that's great to hear. Everything is going on track like I was, honestly, like the way Atlas is performing and then you, I saw like you had such high expectations. I was really worried whether everybody can do it. Yeah, but I've seen as tickets, hit counts and everything that's really going in a good way.
No, Ramal's good. He's good, he's good.
Yeah.
So, I'm really happy to have Ramal in my team.
Yeah, yeah, no, they're both excellent. I appreciate both of them.
Okay, thank you so much Nick for your time. We'll meet next month and if there's anything you can ping me.
Okay, you too. Thanks A lot. Yeah.
Obviously, I would, but there hasn't been, so we're all good.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you so much, Nick, for your time. Thanks. Bye.